[Music]
healthy ecosystems support rich
biodiversity
the akavango delta hosts one of the most
vibrant on earth
pristine water from angola
becomes the life force that sustains a
vast variety of species
two on the right one on the left there
[Music]
each plays its part in supporting the
system
from the smallest
[Music]
to the largest
year round in the delta termites create
nest mounds that form thousands of
islands
plant life takes root reciting nutrients
from the water and fortifying the soil
elephants also build the delta
the planet's largest population live
here
as ecological engineers they shape the
landscape around them
less than a week old seeds are sprouting
already the fresh elephant tracks are
from a big lone ball you can see they're
all torn apart so he's opening up a
clearing here
and as a steward he's left this one
he's gonna let it grow up they're
choosing and managing this landscape
it's such an important function and
without them
the balance that we speak about is lost
the delta is protected in botswana
but it's part of an ecosystem that
extends back to its angolan source
waters through unprotected land
threats like land clearance are
diminishing wildlife habitats
risking the whole ecosystem
that is why national geographic is
joined by de beers through the ocavango
eternal partnership to help ensure the
biodiversity that supports this delicate
ecosystem is protected
akavango eternal is building on research
started by the national geographic
okavango wilderness project who have
studied the source rivers that supply
the delta
so far over 50 species new to science
have been discovered
working together with local scientists
and governments akavanga eternal will
expand this research supporting the
protection of these species and their
habitats
connecting angola to botswana through
one of the largest conservation
corridors in the world
so that wildlife can exist safely
supported by an ecosystem that keeps
nature thriving and water flowing
[Music]
you